Nachschub für die Front bei ihrer
Gegenoffensive verlor die ukrainische
Armee einiges an Material wenige
schnelle Panzer wie diese etwa die
Truppen nach vorne bringen und
Feuerschutz bieten vom Typ Bradley
liefern die USA nun weitere 30 vom Typ
Striker 25 dazu Munition Raketen
Flugabwehrsysteme Material im Wert von
500 Millionen Dollar
wir bringen das Material so schnell wie
möglich dorthin und wie wir in der
Vergangenheit schon bewiesen haben
können wir Dinge sehr schnell in
Bewegung bringen natürlich werde ich
hier nicht verraten wann genau das eine
oder andere ankommt aber auf dem
Schlachtfeld wird das alles sehr rasch
eintreffen
mit Spannung wurde erwartet ob die USA
auch Raketen großer Reichweite liefern
die die Ukraine schon seit Monaten
fordert dazu heute kein Wort das 41
Hilfspaket der USA kommt zu einer Zeit
in der Russland nach dem Putschversuch
von Wagner destabilisiert scheint
dennoch auf die Situation dort
abgestimmt haben die USA das Paket nicht
der Krieg in der Ukraine geht weiter die
illegale Besatzung durch Russland geht
weiter diese Tatsache werden wir nicht
aus den Augen verlieren und wir werden
weiterhin eng mit der Ukraine
zusammenarbeiten um ihr all jene
Fähigkeiten zur Verfügung zu stellen die
sie für die von ihr geplanten und
durchgeführten Operationen benötigt
welche Rolle spielt die wagnergruppe in
Zukunft in diesem Konflikt
immerhin konnte der Wagner Boss wohl mit
einem komfortablen Jet nach Belarus
fliegen so bestätigte dortige Diktator
den Goschen sprach von Gerechtigkeit die
wollen uns erdrosseln wir marschieren
nach Moskau und ich sagte auf halbem Weg
werden sie dich zerquetschen wie
Ungeziefer
hat Putin sich behauptet macht und Staat
stabilisiert sondern Auftritt gestern
vor stabil anmutenden Personal sollte
das wohl ausstrahlen doch er muss
zugeben dass russische Rebellen
russische Soldaten töteten das schwächt
ihn genau wie die Bilder der von ihm
finanziell hochgerüsteten Privatarmee
auf dem Weg nach Moskau ausgerechnet die
soll jetzt in die reguläre Armee
integriert werden
das sind 15 bis 30.000 Soldaten mit
Panzern Raketen und der Fähigkeit eine
Bande zu bilden die nicht nur gegen die
Ukraine kämpft sondern auch Russen tötet
zu allerdings bleiben die USA lieber auf
Sicherheitsabstand Russlands Putsch
Russlands Problem die Militärhilfe für
die Ukraine läuft davon unbeeindruckt
weiter
und kurz vor seinem Abflug nach
Washington spreche ich jetzt mit dem
Bundesverteidigungsminister Boris
Pistorius von der SPD schönen guten
Morgen
ja schönen guten Morgen Herr Minister
wir haben es gerade gesehen die USA hat
noch mal Militärhilfe in Höhe von einer
halben Milliarde Dollar beschlossen und
viele Politiker und Expertinnen sagen ja
dass dieses Jahr das entscheidende Jahr
in der Ukraine sei warum ist das so und
was ist wenn die Ukraine in diesem Jahr
sich nicht durchsetzen kann
also die erste Einschätzung beteiligt
das ist mit großer Wahrscheinlichkeit
eine entscheidendes Jahr sind
entscheidende Monate jetzt deswegen ist
Deutschland ja vor einigen Wochen auch
noch mal mit einem großen
Unterstützungspaket im Umfang von 2,7
Milliarden Euro rausgegangen das
unterstützt die Ukraine nachhaltig wir
sind inzwischen derzeit stärkste
Unterstützer der Ukraine nach den USA
und was passiert wenn die Offensive
nicht den gewünschten Erfolg hat den
erhofften Erfolg hat das zu beurteilen
müssen wir uns aufheben dann wenn es
soweit ist falls es soweit kommt ich
setze auf die große Offensive auf die
Gegend Offensive und alles andere wird
sich finden sie fliegen gleich nach
Washington und treffen dort ihren
US-amerikanischen Amtskollegen die
Amerikaner werden ja sicher fordern dass
ich Deutschland noch mehr engagiert in
der NATO wie wollen Sie Washington
erklären dass Deutschland beim
vereinbarten zwei Prozent Ziel der NATO
also zwei Prozent des
Bruttoinlandsprodukts für Verteidigung
auszugeben immer noch hinterher hängt
zum einen würde ich wenn das auch nur
ein schwacher Trost ist darauf verweisen
dass die Mehrzahl der NATO-Staaten
dieses Ziel noch nicht erreicht hat und
teilweise noch hinter dem liegt was wir
machen aber das kann uns selber nicht
zufriedenstellen deswegen haben wir uns
klar bekannt sowohl der Bundeskanzler in
seiner Zeitenwende Rede im vergangenen
Februar als auch jetzt ganz aktuell
verschriftlich internationalen
Sicherheitsstrategie und auch noch mal
abgebildet in allen anderen Dokumenten
z.B immer richtungsgesetz für das
Sondervermögen wir bekennen uns klar zum
2% Ziel und werden es erreichen aber was
bedeutet das konkret wir haben heute
morgen noch mal nachgeschaut in diesem
Jahr werden die Verteidigungsausgaben
nur rund 1,6% ausmachen also wann werden
es 2% sein und vor allem woher im
Bundeshaushalt soll das Geld kommen
der Blick ins zerrichtungsgesetz für das
Sondervermögen das im vergangenen Jahr
der vom Bundestag beschlossen worden ist
zeigt sehr deutlich dort steht drin wir
wollen in den nächsten Jahren im
Durchschnitt der Jahre unter zur
Hilfenahme des Sondervermögens also Jena
100 Milliarden die zur Verfügung stehen
und dem Einzelplan 14 also meinem
Einzelplan im Haushalt dieses Ziel
erreichen und das werden wir
im aktuellen Ausland Haushalt 2024
bekommen Sie nur 1,8 Milliarden mehr
also davon scheint noch nicht wirklich
viel anzukommen oder
ich wiederhole es gerne noch mal also es
geht um das Sondervermögen das
eingerechnet wird und eingerechnet
werden darauf weil es ausschließlich
Militärausgaben sind und in der Summe
zwischen Einzelplan der Erhöhung und dem
gesamt Einzelplan einerseits und dem
Sondervermögen in seiner Verausgabung
der nächsten Jahre ergibt sich das klare
Erreichen eines Ziels von zwei Prozent
gut bleiben wir noch kurz bei der NATO
falls im kommenden Jahr ein Republikaner
zum US-Präsident gewählt wird würde die
NATO Welt doch ziemlich anders aussehen
vor allem wenn es möglicherweise Donald
Trump wird der die NATO zu seiner
Amtszeit noch für überflüssig erklärt
hat wie groß ist da ihre Sorge
also zunächst mal warten wir mal ab wer
für Republikaner und Demokraten also für
Demokraten ist es klar wer für die
Republikaner antritt wir warten ab wie
die Wahlen ausgehen ich habe keinen
Grund anzunehmen dass die Amerikaner
sich aus der NATO aus Europa
zurückziehen auch wenn es eine andere
Einstellung zur NATO geben mag ich habe
wir haben als Bundesrepublik Deutschland
die USA stets als unseren wichtigsten
Verbündeten betrachtet und erlebt und
ich habe keinen Grund anzunehmen dass
sich das grundlegend verändert aber ja
wenn sich etwas verändert in der
Gewichtsverlagerung in den Indopazifik
oder sonst wohin dann wird die Euro
werden die europäischen Mitglieder der
NATO mehr in die Verantwortung gehen
müssen als das heute der Fall ist aber
ich glaube das ist auch allen bewusst
schauen wir zum Schluss noch auf einen
anderen Krisen hat Mali da gibt es jetzt
eine Resolutionsentwurf der Vereinten
Nationen dass der Einsatz der
unfriedenstruppe am 30 Juni enden soll
also übermorgen was bedeutet das für die
rund 1.000 Bundeswehrsoldaten und
Soldaten vor Ort denn man kann doch
eigentlich davon ausgehen dass nach Ende
des unmandates die Lage dort unsicherer
wird
das muss man nicht zwingend annehmen ich
habe vergangene Woche ausführlich
telefoniert mit dem kommandieren damit
Oberst Bohnsack mit ihm die Lage
erörtert weil ich einen unmittelbaren
Eindruck von vor Ort haben wollte und ja
das ist ja eine unerfreuliche Situation
die jetzt dadurch eintritt aber keine
wovon der kommandierende Herr
oberbodensack ausgeht dass sie eine neue
oder zusätzliche Gefährdung mit sich
bringt für unsere Soldatinnen und
Soldaten für uns bedeutet dass wir
werden noch versuchen noch etwas
schneller rauszukommen rauszugehen aus
Mali aber geordnet und die malische
Regierung hat zugesichert auch bei einer
Beendigung des Mandats eingeordneten
Rückzug zu gewährleisten und darauf wird
es am Ende ankommen und dazu laufen die
Gespräche Fragen an und Antworten von
Bundesverteidigungsminister Boris
Pistorius waren dass der gleich zum
Antrittsbesuch nach Washington fliegt
vielen Dank
sehr gerne vielen Dank